hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video I do apologize for the little bit
of a late ish video it's about three
o'clock when I'm doing this audio
usually I do that at about 2:00 when I
get home but either way I do apologize
but we got stuff to talk about today
about the weekly dead stream for real
quick two really quick things to mention
is that after reading the comments of
last week's video I decided to keep the
old picture as to the new one that I
showed last week a lot of you guys seem
to enjoy that that was the majority vote
so we have the gold picture back so
we're gonna keep that also the Knights
did win yesterday the Knights won season
3 of Esther day so I'm pretty damn happy
about that about time we finally get to
win a season sadly if I'm not mistaken
though we have not gotten the rewards it
because the season is not over but once
that season is over I will show you guys
all the rewards for all the characters
and whatever we happen to get that
season be the way we get stuff to talk
about so let's finally get started so
first up is new the new weekly content
it's going to be 7000 steel and it's
elite outfits this week it's a pretty
long video and elite outfits aren't
really the most exciting thing to look
at I'll leave a timestamp but like right
here if you guys want to skip all those
so just in case but if you do want to
watch it I'll play the video for you
guys right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that was it those were pretty those
weren't too bad once again I'm not
really big on elite outfits I'm more the
mythic guy a lot of the reputation
outfits but either way those are 7000
steel if you do want to get those moving
on though realistic elimination is going
to be a new special event this weekend
yep they finally brought the realistic
game mode back it's gonna be an
elimination no gear stats no guard
stance no feets no boosts and only one
revive that's gonna be happening this
weekend so definitely jump on if you're
one of those realistic fans such as
myself I'm glad to be playing that a lot
this weekend next up today we're
discussing a few of the little to known
issues about the game that because some
people think that the devs don't know
everything that's going on but these are
the known issues that are aware about
the unlock whiffed tech is hopefully
going to be removed soon not all the
unlock tech is fixed but they are aware
of this and are continuously working on
to get those removed when they do be
discovered and pop up and stuff like
that matchmaking issues on PC when
deleting certain types of files it
should verify those files and fix that
the out of stamina bar no longer
blinking is already being fixed in the
next patch minions can stagger players
that's being worked on
warlord shield charge tracking is being
worked on and then match freezing black
screen at the end of Dominion matches
they're still working on this one but
are also looking at the quarter penalty
being applied when the player leaves
because of this bug that has been
affecting me a couple times but it's
nothing too big and then the last two is
the glitch were shinobi sickle rain
combo can be applied to teammates as
well as enemies and Valkyrie no longer
being able to cancel her shield charge
so those are the two things are those
are the multiple things that they are
working on for the issues and they're
hopefully going to be fixed the next
patch or the patch after that and then
next up they had a bit of a Q&A session
they took questions from the twitch chat
the other subreddits of for honor and
this is what they this is what we came
up with for a little bit of a summary
first up they are gonna be releasing a
new rank for ranked mode it's gonna be
called masters rank and you're actually
going to have to keep playing in order
to keep this rank if any of you guys are
aware of ávila overwatch I think I
believe at Diamond level and up you have
to keep playing or your skill level is
going to continuously decrease
until you're at the bottom of the bottom
of that division I don't believe you can
go under it but you'll be at the bottom
possible so the game is making you
actually play instead of being those
people that get to Diamond and then
immediately stop playing next up there's
gonna be some new non gold armors for
Heroes there's gonna be some more armor
for the heroes basically I'm always into
that customization hopefully gladiator
will get some good ones as well as well
some obviously for the other characters
as well next up they're gonna be
addressing the big meme on for honor
with the finding new opponent in the
duel Turner and the and not the duel
tournament in the duel playlist and then
being matched up with the same dude
multiple times in a row they're going to
be fixing that so that it actually gives
you a new person this time as opposed to
you queueing up and getting the same
person and then the next question was
talking about the underplayed modes like
no not really so much to do but more of
skirmish mode to give more extra XP and
more incentive for more players to play
and they said they have ideas but they
can't talk about it at the moment cuz
they are not ready they're still in
development but also working on focusing
players on playlists for certain modes
possibly grouping up game modes into one
playlist like they did at the launch
which was then later removed and then
that was about it it was a pretty short
dev stream although next week is gonna
be a little bit intense because they're
actually going to be showing us what the
mask section is in the outfits tab and
none of you are aware I will put a
there'll be a card on the top right if
you want to click about if you want to
click about my video it was a brief
introduction of what was found during
the pts or if you want you can go into
your actual game and click on any one of
your characters go to the alpha tab and
next to reputation and mythic I believe
is a tab that says masks but it's empty
now a lot of people were really confused
on what that meant that's gonna be
addressed next week as well with a bunch
of other surprises so do check and do
check back next week and I'll once again
keep you guys updated anyway that was
once again the end I hope you all guys
did enjoy leave a like on the video if
you did it really does help me out and
subscribe if you're new to for honor I
post a lot of four on our content it
being discussion videos news videos
upcoming stuff all these types of leaks
anything has to do with for honor that
is news related ish I'm gonna be jumping
on that and then with that guys when to
most of recent videos are gonna be on
screen for you guys to watch it was once
again a couple other dev stream recap so
if you didn't
miss those and with that guys I hope you
have a great rest of your week and
weekend and I'll see you all later and
peace out